What are the best ways to get the blood sugar level lowered?
So if you're testing your blood glucose levels, number one, make sure you're testing it
in a fast-eating state
and make sure you're testing it kind of around the same time every day.
Because your blood sugar is gonna go up after you eat, so make sure you don't make that mistake and you and you're testing it too short of a time
after you've eaten.
So boy, and if you've been at a good lower carbohydrate diet and your blood glucose levels are still high, sometimes you could do everything right and you still can't get that blood glucose level down.
Partly because of, well, there's many different factors in blood glucose level.
There's new types of functional testing out there called HOMA testing.
It's a homeostatic metabolic assessment 2, that's what it's called, HOMA 2.
And it is, and there's, it's new markers to help a person assess, assess, help a doctor assess a patient when their insulin levels are normal and their glucose level is, is more in syndrome X, which would be considered free diabetic state.
So you're trying to help assess the person and get them on a changed diet.
But generally, to lower a person's glucose levels, you're decreasing your carbohydrate loan, first of all, and you're trying to eat more things that have a lower glycemic index that are breaking down into glucose that are taking longer to break down to glucose.
So, like even if I'm going to eat a potato, if I cook a potato and then refrigerate it or freeze it and then heat it up and eat it tomorrow, it's going to have more resistant starch and it's going to have a lower glycemic index that if I could dip a potato and eat the potato.
So you're keeping an eye on glycemic index levels, generally keeping an eye on your carbohydrate consumption is going to be the best way to do that.
But you might be a person like many people like I've been doing that for years and I cannot get my glucose levels down.
Well, there can be some nutrients that can help you.
That's one of the reasons why I'm such a big one reason why I'm such a big fan of burberry.
Burberry is a great nutrient to help lower blood glucose levels and help take some burden off of patients that are struggling with diabetes.
Burberry is also a killer of age.
Pylori, burberry is a killer of cancer, burberry is a balancer of your gut.
Burberry does a lot of great things, but what does one thing that helps bring glucose levels down?
There's other nutrients like chromium picolidate that can help bring glucose levels down.
So, and then you got to consider why a glucose level is up.
Could it be stress on the pancreas?
So the pancreas is struggling, even though your insulin levels are number higher.
That's one of the benefits of doing an index, almost two tests, which because I can give you some percent insulin resistance and percent insulin stress on that test.
Though, I mean, I never typically recommend that test because all our patients are already motivated to be on a fairly good diet.
But that test is good for people who maybe don't have cancer, but aren't really motivated to be on a good diet,
but then you could show things before they're got full diabetes that they're, that they're kind of heading in that direction by doing that test.
So, trying to get your blood sugar levels lowered, you could use specific nutrients with it and mainly through diet.
But, and then there's some people with that insulin resistant issue that it's really hard to do that.
So, then supporting the pancreas, we've seen that happen before by people that are diabetic and they can't get their levels lowered by putting them on basically a Dr. Kelly pancreatic enzyme approach diet to help support take a lot of stress off their pancreas.
Has the approval of some people to help as well.